Mmh, yeah, ah, aha, aha.
Hallo ihr Lieben und herzlich willkommen, das sind Stefan und Florentina Mikrofon. Sie droppen von den Jog, das war züchtig wie Coase, jetzt gibt es einen schönen Spaß und wir heben an. Yo, what up, herzlich willkommen, schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid bei der neuen Hausaufbahn von Das Podcast Ufo. Fest des Friedens, hallo, herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge Das Podcast Ufo mit Florentin Tini. Liebesvertraglich verpflichtet, einmal Fest des Friedens. Hallo, herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge Das Podcast UFO mit Florentin, Thini, Will und Stefan. Du bist betraglich verpflichtet, einmal Fest des Friedens in dieser Folge zu sagen. Und das ist jetzt geschehen. Vielen Dank an die unsere kleinen... Fest des Friedens, Trademark. ...und unsere Türöffner Rosa und Patrick, die uns hier mal mit einem kleinen urbanen Flair bescheren. So muss es ja auch mal sein. Flair bescheren. Es darf auch mal hip sein. Es darf, gerne. Ja, nee, da möchte ich ja, dass ihr euch nicht zurückhaltet mit deinen hippen Intros. Wenn ihr sagt, okay, der Podcast ist nicht der hipste der Welt, zugegeben. No, wir sind cool, wir sind schon hip. Ich finde, sind wir cool? Also erstmal, wahrscheinlich das Uncoolste, was man machen kann, ist zu definieren, was die Wörter genau bedeuten. Und auch zu sagen, wir sind cool. Soweit ich weiß, ist hip, dass dass man weiss, was cool ist. Also wer hip ist, der kann sagen, ey, das ist mega uncool. Wohingegen Coolness ja in gewisser Weise auch eine Selbstvergessenheit mit einschließt, so dass man selber gar nicht merkt, dass man cool ist. Wer unbedingt cool sein will, ist nicht cool. Ja gut, aber dann wären ja für die Tonisten eigentlich die hipsten Menschen. Da würde ich mal behaupten, dass es ein großes Fragezeichen würde ich daran machen. Naja, ob die wirklich wissen, was cool ist. Ich glaube, du musst schon in der Hood sein. Das ist ihr Job zu wissen, was cool ist, oder nicht? Du musst schon in der Hood sein, du musst mit den Leuten flowen, dass du weißt, was los ist. Wenn du da in deinem Elfenbeinturm da oben mit der goldenen Feder schreibst, da kommst du nicht an die Kids ran, an die Homies. Du sollst nicht so oft sagen, dass du an die Kids ran willst. Ihr müsst mehr an die Kids ran. Auch hier meine vertragliche Pflicht nicht erfüllt. Ja, wir wurden verklagt. Auch um das noch mal kurz abzuhaken, einfach um hier noch mal die Gerichtskosten reinzuholen. Ja, das war nichts. Und zwar gab es grosse Beschwerden zum Thema Poolnudel. Ja, und das wurde jetzt juristisch, das hat ein bisschen gedauert, das wurde juristisch einmal, da musste Justitia selbst nochmal runterkommen.
Zwei Wochen, also. Naja gut, immerhin, also ich meine
unsere rasenden Mühlen der
Justiz, da musste sie selber
nochmal extra aus dem Büro kommen, aus dem
Urlaub. Justitia war eigentlich schon im Urlaub
für Weihnachten. War auf Gran Canaria,
war Justitia, war auf Gran Canaria.
Leider, ich hab da keinen Bock, hier in der
Kälte zu sitzen. So, da ist sie dann natürlich schon mal weggeflogen. Und deswegen gab es in gewisser Weise Probleme. So oder so, wir haben massive Schwierigkeiten, was die Situation angeht. Es geht um das Wort Derelektion. Wir kommen noch mal einmal zurück. Wir holen alle Leute in die Lore. rein dieser ja doch sehr komplizierten Geschichte, Florian hat Pullnudeln gefunden, Ende. Genau, in Verzweiflung bin ich in einer Nacht, in der mich das Feuer verlassen hat, bin ich in den Keller eingedrungen, das erste Mal in meinem Leben, also klar könnt ihr jetzt gerne auch tiefenpsychologisch gerne deuten, ja, irgendwie, ich gehe in den Keller meiner selbst und finde dort Pullnudeln und so. Stell dir mal vor, bitte. Fallus, alles klar, könnt ihr das gerne machen.
Stell dir mal vor, den Film Inception mit der genau der gleichen Epicness im Soundtrack. Und dann reist da das Team, Tom Hardy, Joseph Gordon-Levitt und Leonardo DiCaprio reisen gemeinsam in das Innere von dir. Und haben so geile, keine Ahnung, auch so Level-Designed und so. Und dein Unterbewusstsein wurde darauf getrennt, darauf getrimmt, Leute abzusondern, die eindringen wollen und so weiter. Level, Level, Level. Und dann haben die auch dann diesen Safe in deinem Kopf geplant, um dir selber, um dir was zu extracten. Komm rein, mach den Safe auf und in deinem Kopf sind unterbewusst nur Poolnudel. Stell dir das mal vor, das wäre dein Unterbewusstsein. Das finde ich gut. Aber kann man natürlich auch viel reinbefrischen. Nichts, glaube ich, mehr. Also wenn man dann Safe aufmacht, einfach, keine Ahnung, einfach Poolnudel. Eine Poolnudel liegt da rum. Wofür steht das? Wir brauchen noch Zeichendeuter, wir brauchen Symbolisten, Symboliker, die uns das Ganze mal so ein bisschen darstellen. Also mein Vater hat mir damals die Welt erklärt und hat gesagt, Sohn, es gibt drei Arten, auf die man was bekommen kann. Okay. Ja, hör mir zu. Es gibt Kaufen, Schenken, Erben und das war's. Es gibt nichts darüber. Ist Schenken, ist Erben nicht ein Teil von Schenken?
Nein, weil man tot ist.
Kann ich jetzt wie ein anderer Geschwister auch die Geschenke aufmachen?
Warum sitzen wir hier noch in der Küche, in der gefließten Küche?
Erst weil du mir sagst, was das für eine Art von Eigentumübertragung ist.
Okay.
Handelt es sich dabei um Schenken, Erben, Kaufen oder alle drei? Ich glaube, beim Weihnachten handelt es sich um Schenken. Völlig korrekt. Du kriegst ein weiteres Geschenk. Danke. Oh, schön. Ein Buch über das deutsche Grundrecht. Erbrecht. Ein Erbrechtsbuch. Und deswegen, und jetzt stellt sich raus sich raus, falsch, stellt sich raus, all die Jahre wurde ich fehlgeleitet, denn es stimmt nicht, es gibt noch einen weiteren, es gibt nämlich Schenken, Kaufen, Erben und die Derelektion. Sehr ungelenkes Wort, Moment, was beschreibt das genau? Derelektion bezeichnet als Rechtsbegriff die Aufgabe des Besitzes an einer Sache in der erkennbaren Absicht der Preisgabe des Eigentums durch den Eigentümer. Also, klassisches Zurücklassen. Weggeben, zurücklassen, Abwerfen, Verlassen. Zurücklassen, finde ich nicht so schlecht. Über Bord werfen. Also offensichtlich, dass man es nicht mitnehmen wollte, nicht vergessen hat. Vergessen ist nämlich kein Besitzabtritt, richtig? Die nähere Definition ist noch wesentlich länger, da müssen wir jetzt nicht durch, aber ich glaube, technisch heißt es, wenn man was weggibt und es ist einem egal, was damit passiert, die Preisgabe des Eigentums, so oder so. Klassisch, eigentlich alles, was in Horrorfilmen, wenn die neue Familie dann in das neue Haus bezieht, was da noch so in der Mitte des Raumes steht, diese kleine Spieluhr, was oben auf dem Erker, wie heißt das, auf dem Dachboden liegt. Auf dem Dach, nee, auf dem, okay, was auf dem Sims liegt. Nimm dieses Wort. Nimm dieses Wort, werden wir weitersuchen. Transzendenz, ja. Das, was oben auf dem Dachboden liegt. Giebel. Giebel in der Mitte des Raumes quasi, was das Kind entdeckt natürlich in der ersten Nacht im neuen Hause. Das ist eine Derelektion, das wurde zurückgelassen, ein Relikt der alten Besitzer, die schon lange gestorben sind, was man dann auf dem VHS-Volkohlen steht. Gerichtsverhandlung der deutsche Staat gegen den Teufel. Sie werden angeklagt, eine verfluchte Spieluhr auf dem Dachboden eines verlassenen Hauses zurückgelassen zu haben. Wie plädieren Sie? Ich bin der Teufel schuldig. Wie schuldig? Naja, ich habe... Moment. Sie sagen, dass sie mutwillig, absichtlich ...
Nee, also viele Dämonen und Dämoninnen arbeiten für mich.
Und auf diesem Wege möchte ich gerne sagen,
der Teufel gendert sowas von.
Ich weiß nicht, welches Statement ich gerade als Persona mache.
Aber na ja, ich möchte nur sagen, also viele Dämonen und Dämonen arbeiten für mich und es ist ein Gang und Gäbe bei uns, dass wir Dinge zurücklassen. Der Lektion. Sind Sie sich sicher, dass Sie sich auf dieses Rechtskonstrukt stützen möchten? Habe ich einen Anwalt? Der Anwalt des Teufels, habe ich nicht, arbeitet nicht literally Al Pacino für mich?
Al Pacino?
Ich bin Al Pacino, der Anwalt des Teufels, im Namen des...
Ich dachte, Sie können sich aussuchen, in welcher Gestalt Sie erscheinen.
Al Pacino.
Al Pacino, okay. Wollen Sie noch mal reinkommen oder wollen Sie, dass jetzt vor uns, wollen Sie die Gestalt wandeln?
Weil aktuell sind Sie in Ziegenbock.
Okay, Achtung.
Das hätten wir jetzt auch sparen können, da hätten sie auch kurz rausgehen können. Teufel, Teufel, ich bin ein Teufel. Also, Sie haben die Spieluhr verflucht und zurückgelassen. Ja, das war... Mit welchem Ziel, warum machen Sie das? Um Leuten etwas auszuwischen. Um etwas auszuwischen und einen Schrecken einzujagen. Damit Leute sich so richtig schaudern. Also gut, damit ergeht folgendes Urteil, sie kriegen zwei Jahre Strafvollzugsanstalt auf Bewährung. Oh. Ach so. Also jetzt Vorsicht, Freundchen. Ich glaube, sie können sich ändern. Ich habe in ihrer Augen gesehen, in ihrer kalten Ziegenaugen und ich habe gesehen, dass sie sich ändern können. Sie haben mich überzeugt. Sie haben meine roten Augen geschaut und dann sind sie zum Schluss gekommen, dass ich mich doch ändern kann. Ich glaube an sie. Sie glauben, dass was Gutes in mir steckt. Ich glaube an sie. Ich bin der Teufel. Das ist jetzt auch, also, ich weiß auch nicht, welches Statement das jetzt genau ist, dass im deutschen Rechtssystem der Te Teufel nochmal davon kommt. So, unabhängig davon fertig. Danke. So, kommen wir zu Santa Claus. vom Bundesministerium für Bildung und jetzt könnt ihr daraus ziehen, was ihr wollt. Die Interpretation davon wird noch eine ganze Weile dauern, auf jeden Fall. So oder so heißt es, dass ich jetzt tatsächlich in Besitz von einigen Puhnudeln bin.
Ich habe sogar extra nochmal nachgeschaut, und zwar, weil ich war in der Situation angespannt, ich stand unter Stress, ich war auf der Suche nach Strom.
Jetzt dachte ich mir, schaue ich mir das Ganze nochmal im Lichte meiner Vernunft an.
Und ich habe runtergeschaut und habe sogar noch eine Box gefunden, die war hinter der Tür, ganz rechts, wenn man reinkommt, war noch eine Box und zwar diese Wasserspritzstangen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du die kennst, die man so aufziehen muss und dann saugt man die so voller Wasser und dann kann man spritzen, die haben auch so das Äussere einer Poolnudel. Also nach dem Motto, Schatz, der Umzugswagen ist voll, okay, lass alle Wasserspielzeuge zurück. Ja, oder Schatz, wir haben noch einen Platz. Entscheide dich, Poolnudeln, Spritzpistolen oder Schlauchboot. Schatz, wir haben noch einen Platz im Umzugskasse. Oh mein Gott. Warum haben wir alle Wasserspielzeuge zurückgelassen? Weil die am leichtesten sind. Gut, dann Schlauchboot, komm. Bist du dir sicher? Ja, lass sowohl die Spritzpistolen als auch die Poolnudeln zurück.
Und weißt du was? Tauchbrille auch zurück.
Okay, gut, dann entscheiden wir uns für das Schlauchboot.
Nein, die Tauchbrille nehme ich noch mit.
Setz dich auf, setz dich auf.
Acht Stunden nach Stuttgart kannst du auch aufsetzen die ganze Zeit.
Oh ja, das ist spannend.
Also man hat sich entschieden, die zwei Wasserpark-Utensilien zurückzulassen.
Ja, hat man derelegiert und ich habe sie freudig anderelegiert und das gehört jetzt mir. Okay, also ich behaupte nämlich, wenn du etwas, zum Beispiel einen Elektro-Grossgegenstand, wie ein alter Röhrenfernseher oder sowas, wenn du da Derelektion betreibst als Ausziehender und den zurücklässt, nennt man das, glaube ich, auch negative Schenkung. Also, naja, weiß ich nicht, inwiefern Derelektion auch eine Schenkung ist, aber es gibt ja auch negative Schenkungen. Du kannst jemandem etwas vermachen, das gibt es nämlich nicht, also das darf man nicht im rechtlichen Sinne, aber natürlich rein ja, logisch kann man das natürlich machen. Du kannst ihm jemandem etwas Schulden schenken und dieser grosse Bildsch grosse Bildschirm, wenn du den loswerden willst und nicht behalten willst, sind die ja mit Kosten verbunden, weil du den zu einer Müllkippe bringen musst oder was auch immer und vielleicht kostest du sogar noch Geld, so alte Elektro-Grossgegängnisse abzugeben. Und dann ist es im rechtlichen Sinne nicht erlaubt quasi und völlig legitim, diese Schenkung abzulehnen.
So, und jetzt kommen wir nochmal zu Ihnen, Herr Klaus.
Ja.
Sie haben jetzt dieser Fridolina geschenkt 16 Paar Socken.
Genau. Das war eine Nichte.
Frau Fridolina, können Sie vielleicht nochmal Ihren Wunschzettel vorzeigen?
Was steht da drauf? Können Sie es vorlesen, Herr Klaus? Hier steht doch ganz gross oben drauf. Playstation 5. Ne, Playstation 5. Jetzt, Herr Klaus, Sie haben ja die Empfangsbestätigung für diesen Wunschzettel ausgefüllt. Das ist doch Ihre Unterschrift, oder? Ja, ich weiß nicht, warum meine Nichte Durchschriften bereitet. Bitte beahnten wir Sie einfach nur die Fragen, die wir Ihnen stellen. Ja, Herr Klaus? Mein Vater hat mir immer gesagt, ich soll Durchschriften sammeln. Das ist auch gut so, das machst du gut. So, Sie haben also den Wunschzettel bekommen, da steht drauf, Playstation 5. Warum fünd Sie als Vater als mein Bruder? Moment, ich bin der Sohn von Klaus? Nein, nein. Die sind mein Bruder. Ich bin Patrick Klaus. Papa, Papa, du führst doch jetzt gerade, das ist ein Prozess. Ja, natürlich. Ihr stellt jetzt mal, ihr antwortet bitte nur auf die Fragen, die ich euch stelle. Herr Klaus, Sie haben also von diesem Wunschzettel gewusst, auf dem Playstation 5 steht, haben Fridolina aber trotzdem 16 Paar Socken geschenkt. Wie kam es dazu? Führen Sie uns da mal durch. Also die Playstation 5, das war für alle kein einfaches Jahr, so und die Playstation 5 einfach sau teuer. Was braucht man immer und die braucht man auch nicht, jetzt um den kalten Winter zu kommen. Ich bin der Onkel und ich verstehe nicht, warum ihr Vater das nicht besorgt dann. Die Playstation 5 ist glaube ich nicht für mich gedacht gewesen. Ich sitze gerade nicht ich an der Anklagebank, sondern Sie. Naja, ich verstehe halt nicht, warum wir jetzt das hier vor allen, vor dem ganzen Tribunal der Familie, das Essen wird kalt, der Trutan ist aus dem Ofen. Ich möchte nur sagen, ich finde das ein krasses Geschenk für mich. Ich bin ein freiberuflicher Künstler und ich habe dieses Jahr ein einziges Gemälde verkauft, an euch und ihr wollt noch verhandeln, mit eurem Bruder.
So, und das fand ich eh schon daneben.
Gut. Mehr habe ich nicht verdient dieses Jahr
und deswegen habe ich ein paar Socken geschenkt, okay?
Dann rufen wir jetzt in den Zeugenstand
Rudolf.
Hi!
Hi, ich bin Rudolf! Sie arbeiten ja mit dem Santa Claus zusammen, ist das korrekt? Ja. Und so wie es in Ihrer Berufsbezeichnung auf Xing steht, sind Sie da auch für die Steuern verantwortlich. Ja, und berufssuchend. Aha, berufssuchend. Seit wann? November. Immer wenn der Stress anfängt, denke ich mir, oh nein, nicht noch ein Jahr. Das heißt, Sie haben sich um die Steuern des Herrn Klaus gekümmert. Können Sie mal ungefähr für uns in der Größenordnung zusammenfassen, was Herr Klaus so in einem Jahr einnimmt? Oh, Klaus nichts. Gar nichts? Er nimmt sehr wenig ein, gibt aber, hat unglaublich viele Ausgaben. Für mich steuerlich ein Paradies. Herr Klaus hat sehr, sehr wenig Einnahmen. Wie kommen dann diese, also was sind das für Einnahmen? In Form von, naja, ab und zu liegt auf einem Wunschzettel mal Geld oder sehr viel Orangen. Orangen und Walsocken werden gefüllt für den Weihnachtsmann. Und Ausgaben, also drei Milliarden Kinder auf der Welt? Ja, das sind die 324 Milliarden Euro, die ich da genau aufgeschrieben hatte, die gehen ab jeweils. Das heißt insgesamt 14 Euro Einnahmen an 30 Milliarden Ausgaben, da ist ja ein bisschen Minus. 14 Euro Einnahmen und 529 orangischen Einnahmen. Und was bleibt dann ungefähr als Minus noch übrig am Ende des Jahres? Ungefähr Minus diese 324 Milliarden. Okay, Also Sie unterstützen also, was Herr Klaus sagt, dass er kein Geld hatte für eine Playstation 5 von Fridolina hier. Jetzt verstehe ich, Herr Klaus, ja. Gut. Na, damit sind Sie freigesprochen. Dankeschön. So, der nächste Fall. Robin Hood. Steuerbetrüger. Steuerbetrüger Hood. Heiratsschwindler. Herr Hood, mein Name ist Hood. Robin. Ihr Motto ist ja, ich klaue von den Reichen und gebe es den Armen. Ich dachte gerade ganz anders. Ich dachte nicht, dass das der Weihnachtsmann ist, den du mit Herrn Klaus meinst, sondern ich dachte, das wäre ein random Familienvater.
Und ich finde es auch völlig legitim.
Santa Claus, okay.
Ah ja, genau, das kam dann auch an am Ende. Gegen Ende. Ich finde es völlig legitim, wenn sich Eltern und Verwandte vom Wundzettel entfernen, um was eigenes zu schenken. Ich habe dieses Jahr auch die Erfahrung gemacht bei mir selber. ich möchte überrascht werden. Ich brauche lieber, ich brauche lieber, hör doch auf, was du nicht checkst, Leute checken nicht, Leute checken nicht, die Geschenke sind nur für den Schenkenden. Ja. So, deswegen macht, was ihr wollt. Nein, aber du als Beschenkter kannst dem Beschenkenden eine Freude machen, wenn du dir klar wünschst. Ich wünsche mir Simpsons Comic Ausgabe 286 die mit Bart vorne auf dem Cover, Punkt. Und dann besorgt er das und gibt's dir und dann ist Schluss. Komm mir nicht mit, ich möchte überrascht werden, damit sagst du, kümmere dich noch mehr um mich, du musst den ganzen Tag an mich denken, bitte. Du kennst mich doch. Oh, bitte mach dir noch mehr. Oh, ich will, dass du ganz viel an mich denkst. Nein, mein ganzes Leben ist ein Sch... Ich sag euch die ganze Zeit, was man beschenken kann. Ich mit meinen Phasen bin der Dankbarst zu beschenken. Wir haben dir einen Roller geschenkt, wir haben dir eine Flasche Whisky geschenkt. Ja, was ist daraus geworden? Naja, aber es war doch... Habe ich mich gefreut über das Geschenk? Ja. So, nehme ich euch das Übel? Die K.O.-Tropfen der Whisky und ... Spotify Premium-Abo, einen Roller und Whisky geschenkt. Ja. Hat nicht funktioniert. Gut, ich habe mir noch einen Helm gewünscht, den habe ich nicht bekommen, aber ... Ja, wir wollten dich überraschen. Ich möchte jedenfalls sagen, weil ich behaupte mal, Leute, es gibt Menschen, da ist jeder unterschiedlich, aber die meisten Menschen schenken sehr gerne. Die gucken dich an. Einspruch? Nein. Einspruch? Nein, nein, nein. Es gibt so viele Menschen, die gerne ... Ja, abgelehnt. Du hast noch abgelehnt. Es gibt so viele Menschen, die sehr gerne schenken. Die geben dir was und schauen dich mit ihren grossen Augen an und freuen sich darüber, dass du es auspackst. Und du kannst dich gar nicht so doll freuen. Und ich finde eher, dann Geschenk zu bekommen, viel anstrengender.
Aber diese Leute haben sich Gedanken gemacht
und wollen dir was schenken,
wollen dir damit zeigen, wie sehr sie an dich denken
und so weiter. Wenn du denen sagst,
ich wünsche mir Folgendes,
und am besten, ich kann es dir sogar noch schon bei Amazon bestellen,
dann gebe ich es dir. Boah, ich muss mich so
hart distanzieren von dir gerade.
Wir waren uns noch nie ferner. Ich finde das so bescheuert.
Dieses, jemandem genau etwas sagen, kann man natürlich machen, bei Leuten, die nicht gerne schenken. So, aber ich behaupte, so viele Leute geben vor allem Geschenke, und ich bin bei Weihnachten auch so, ich gebe lieber. Ich finde das viel geiler, so etwas zu geben. Wir sind doch auch in einem Alter, wo die Geschenke, die man sich schenkt, kann man sich auch kaufen, Aber in dem Moment, wo du etwas ... Ich finde, ich schenke so gerne was.
Und da habe ich irgendwo im Jahr gemerkt,
was die Person sich geschenkt hat.
Gebt das dann Weihnachten ab.
Und dann die Augen, die leuchtenden Augen.
Hast du meinen Geschenk da?
Wir schenken uns nichts.
Wir sagen immer, wir schenken uns nichts.
Ich dachte, du schenkst so gerne.
Bei Leuten, die ich
liebe.
Okay.
Deine Ehrlichkeit ist dein Geschenk.
Das ist doch auch nicht schlecht.
Nein, wir schenken uns nichts.
Und das ist auch übrigens
ein Satz, wenn der fällt,
problematisch für Leute, die wie ich gerne schenken.
Nee, aber dir schenke ich nichts,
weil du hast es, überrascht zu werden. Und das ist mein Geschenk an dich, bitteschön. Dankeschön. Hier hast du kein Geschenk. Die Entlastung, dass ich dir was schenken muss, ist dein Geschenk. Ja, ehrlich gesagt, ja. Weil dann stell dir mal vor, du musst mir dann auch was schenken, und das wäre der grösste, grösste Horror für dich. Dann würdest du jetzt noch, weil wenn ich dir, du bist ja dann auch fair und nett und wurde erzogen, und dann würde ich dir etwas schenken, und dann würdest du sagen, jetzt muss ich dir auch was schenken. Und dann würdest du wahrscheinlich Weihnachten nicht genießen können, weil du den ganzen Blickst du nicht Stefan schenken. Und es darf ja auch keine, wahrscheinlich erzählt das im Podcast, es darf keine Enttäuschung sein, es darf nichts Peinliches sein. Ein hippes cooles Geschenk sein. War es eine schlechte Idee, ihm eine Podcast-Ufo-Tasse zu schenken von unseren neuen Emailletassen, die ja jetzt im Shop verfügbar sind, für jeden, der vielleicht noch schnell ein Geschenk braucht. Ein Heiligabend. Das ist ein schlechtes Geschenk von mir? Nein, darüber freut sich jeder. Das stimmt, jeder weiss jetzt, dass ich einige Poolnudeln habe und die kann ich jetzt wie so der Zauberer in so Fantasy-Filmen, dass dann irgendwie die verteilt werden und dann in hundert Jahren, wenn ich wiederkomme als böser Magier, müssen die alle hundert Poolnudeln sammeln aus dem ganzen Königreich, zusammenbringen und nur dann kann man mich vernichten mit den Poolnudeln. Ja, das ist ja auch nicht schlecht. Sind die nicht uralt und zerbröselnd im Pool? Ich habe sie noch nicht aufgemacht. Sie sind noch Kragfakt? Die sind OVOP, OVOP, die sind dabei und ich denke, ich kann da noch ein bisschen Profit draus schlagen. Weil ich sage mal, jetzt die aufzumachen, wäre ein Riesenfehler. Also ich bin ja nicht dumm, ich investiere doch antizyklisch, nee, zyklisch, wenn die Sommer, wenn die Bade-Bassings wieder aufgehen, dann komme ich mit meinen Nudeln. Wenn die Bassings wieder aufgehen, Wenn die Sonne und die Bassings aufgehen, dann bin ich dabei, die Wasser-Bassings Bassins aufgehen, dann ... Die Wasser-Bassin. Die Wasser-Bassin. Man sagt Bassin-Bassin. Poul-Noudin. Poul-Noudin. Ah, aber ... Bastardie ... Bastardie-Aqua. OVP ist schon eine komische Abkürzung, ne? Also eigentlich würde man OV sagen. Ja, ja. Weil warum fängt man an, plötzlich Silben abzukürzen? Ja. Original verpackt. Es ist ein Wort, ne? Eigentlich kann man sagen O.
Aber es ist OVP.
OV, wo OV schon weg ist für Originalversionen.
Ach so, ja, kann sein.
Und O ist schon weg für Ostern.
Für Ostern, ja, na klar.
Die haben sich das so früh geschnappt, die Schweine, ey.
Ja, O bis O, ne? Ostern bis Oktober habe ich ...
Vielen Dank für die Grafik im Reddit.
Hat uns jemand eine Grafik gemacht mit den Reifen als Auto, die Os als Reifen bei Auto, wann Sommerreifen, wann Winterreifen. Ich glaube, es ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, euch Hörersplaining gesagt bekommen, was ich zu tun habe und wie bescheuert ich bin, dass ich nicht auf meine Gesundheit und die des Reifen achte. Ich habe nämlich immer noch Sommerreifen drauf, habe ich jetzt herausgefunden. Ich wusste nicht, welche Reifen ich drauf hatte und konnte nicht zum Reifen wechseln fahren, weil ich es unangenehm fand, meine Unwissenheit zu offenbaren, weil ich nicht wusste, welche sind eingelagert, welche sind auf meinem Auto dran. Das ist wie wenn du zum Arzt gehst, um deinen Blinddarm raus zu operieren und der wurde schon raus operiert. Und dann schneiden die dich auf und sagen, ja, Herr Tietze, der ist ja schon raus. Ach, das war das. Ich dachte, die Mandeln. Ich dachte, das war was anderes. Das ist blöd. Das war auch so, die haben mich auch nochmal gefragt, bevor ich dann eingeschläfert wurde von meiner Schlüsselbein-OP, welche Schlüsselbein haben die das angemalt, also mit einem grossen X. Das fand ich nicht so schlecht. Stell dir mal vor, du wachst auf und die haben das Falsche gemacht. Das ist so wirklich schlimm. Ganz, ganz schlimm. Dann ist das eine doppelt geheilt und das andere kaputt. Das andere ist so fucking heile und so wenig Schmerzen und das andere ist so kaputt. Ja. Ja, stimmt, das ist eigentlich eine dumme Idee, den Patienten einzuschläfern und dann machst du auf und sag mal, was war es jetzt, Knie oder Schlüsselbein? Fuck! Warte mal, äh, ähm. Weck ihn auf, weck ihn auf, geht nicht, der schläfert jetzt für zwei Stunden. Hä, wie zwei Stunden, den kann man doch aufwecken? Ich wüsste nicht, der hat doch gerade so eine Dosis bekommen. Ja, warum schläfern Sie denn den ein? Ja, weil Sie gesagt haben, ich stehe ein. Ja, wir brauchen den doch, wir müssen doch, ja, woher sollen wir jetzt wissen, was wir operieren sollen? Ja, ich schätze, kann man das nicht, Sie sind doch Arzt. Was machen Sie denn immer da mit Ihren Fläschchen? Ja, lassen Sie das doch mal. Hä? Sie schläfern immer die Leute ein, bevor wir da operieren. Ja, das ist ja die Idee, damit die keine Schmerzen empfinden. Schmerzen, das ist doch Quatsch, so können wir mit den Leuten nicht reden. Wir wissen ja gar nicht, wir wollen noch fragen, ist es gut so? Lesen Sie doch Ihren Bericht. Tut weh. Welcher Bericht denn?en Sie auch Ihren Bericht, wo Sie operieren sollen, der Operationsbericht. Ich mach das eher so spontan. Synesthesisten, das Musical. Schrecklich. Another terrible musical. Ten-Sie bis zehn. Ein Stern. Ist die Tagline. The next worst musical from them.
Hate them.
Variety. Fuck them.
I'd rather be sleeping.
Fuck those two guys.
Stop making musicals.
Fuck those two guys. New York Times.
Wie ist das schlecht?
Fuck them.
They still make me watch their musicals.
Hate them.
Aber du warst richtig operiert, alles gut,ist du dann wieder der Alte, kann man sagen. Wir haben natürlich charakterlich auch gemerkt, dass sich das schon angeschlagen hat. Er hat mich angeschlagen ausgenommen, ich bin wie ausgetauscht, Klammer zu, Klammer zu, Reifenproblematik. Ihr habt mir gesagt, wie ich erkenne, diese ganze Bilder habe ich auch schon gesehen. Und zwar soll da nämlich auf den Winterreifen ein Frostsymbol sein. Jetzt habe ich schon auch gedacht, wahrscheinlich sind keine Winterreifen drauf und auf Sommerreifen ist nicht eine Sonne drauf.
Ach so, es gibt Normal und Winter, oder wie?
Ja, sozusagen, laut diesen Symboliken.
Das ist doch albern.
Und die sind auch schon alt, deswegen sind die so weirdly dreckig, die Reifen, deswegen kann man auch nicht jegliches Symbol drauf erkennen.
Aber dann habe ich an einem Bild bei Google nämlich auch schon alt, deswegen sind die so weirdly dreckig auch die Reifen, deswegen man kann da auch nicht jegliches Symbol drauf erkennen, aber dann habe ich an einem Bild bei Google nämlich auch schon gesehen, man kann anhand der Rillen des Reifenprofils erkennen, ob man Winter- oder Sommerreifen hat. Sommerreifen sind nämlich deutlich geradliniger und Winterreifen sind mehr verschachtelt, weil die mehr Grip brauchen auf der Strasse, macht ja auch Sinn. Und dann habe ich erkannt, Shit, Sommerreifen sind drauf und habe heute schon einen Termin bekommen.
Also ich fahre gleich schön in die Werkstatt und lasse mir die Reifen wechseln. Ah, das ist doch herrlich. Boxenstop, kleiner Boxenstop eigentlich. Ah, das ist doch herrlich, das ist doch schön. Es ist nicht so herrlich und schön, ich habe da keinen Bock drauf. Ach, du machst das gerne, du magst das, so ein bisschen dieses Motorölgeruch in der Luft. Ja, der Geruch finde ich wirklich schön, nein. Diese hydraulische Hebebühne und so, da bist du doch zu Hause und denkst dir, ah, das hätte ich auch machen können. Wäre ich damals nicht Podcaster geworden, hätte ich das auch machen können. Hier so ein bisschen Schrauben. Wäre ich damals nicht IHK geprüfter Podcaster geworden. Das wissen viele nicht, aber flohen sie nicht, haben die IHK Ausbildung gemacht. Ja, das stimmt. Wir haben alle Scheine da, die hängen hier an der Wand auch, alle unsere Diplome, Abschluss mit Poddy. Dazu noch ganz kurz, weil es gerade richtig gut passt zum Thema Ausbildung. Du hast eine Überleitungsseminar, das war ja das Wochenende Seminar. Ja, genau. In England, in Bristol, da hast du auch noch an der Wand, das sehe ich da. Das hat er sehr prominent aufgehangen. Apropos Überleitungen, wir haben eine Nachricht bekommen, die da genau richtig dazu passt. Und zwar, wir haben ja vor langer Zeit die Hausaufgabe aufgegeben
und Jas beantwortet. Was war die Hausaufgabe?
Ob alle
Sonnensysteme gleich
sind. Ob alle Sonnensysteme
in Jupiter haben.
Ja, das kann sein. Die hat niemand
abgegeben, leider.
Weiß ich nicht mehr.
Es ging darum, um ...
Comedy erfordert Mut, war unser Motto. Nee, aber die Leute sollten dir auch Äste schicken. War unser Mut. Ja, Äste haben wir geschicken, alles flöten. Ich habe nur flöten bekommen. Ich hasse dich. Ich hasse dich, ich hasse die Challenge, ich hasse alles, ich hasse Äste. Und nein, Jasper antwortet auf unsere Hausaufgabe von Kalenderwoche 51, keine Ahnung, was das bedeutet.
Jetzt.
Nächstes Jahr, ja. Auf jeden Fall haben wir mal aufgerufen zum Thema, ja, sagen wir mal Humor gegen den Strom.
Und Jasper schreibt. Beantworteten alle Schüler und Schülerinnen der Reihe nach, sie würden gerne Steuerberater werden. Sie waren ja auch in der Ausbildung zum Steuerfach gehilfen. Ich war einer der Letzten in der Reihe. Und nachdem vor mir etwa 20 Menschen den gleichen Wunsch geäussert haben, dachte ich, es wäre an der Zeit, die Stimmung etwas aufzulockern, die Situation aufzulegen. Sehr ernste Situationen, die nach einer sehr ernsten Antwort erfordern, sollen die Leute mal brechen. Also die Situation, Ausbildung zur Steuerfachhilfe. Stark, stark. Was möchtest du mal werden? Steuerberater. Was möchtest du werden? Steuerberaterin. Was möchtest du mal werden? Steuerberater. Zwanzig Mal hatten wir das jetzt. Und jetzt schreibt Jasper, ich dachte es wäre in der Zeit, die Stimmung etwas aufzulockern. Ich antwortete also, dass ich gerne Astronaut werden möchte, aber wohl in der falschen Schlange gestanden haben musste. Die Reaktion auf diesen zugegebenermaßen schlechten Gag blieb komplett aus. Es folgten ein paar Momente der Stille, bis der Lehrer meine Sitznachbarin anschaute und diese als Berufswunsch Steuerberaterin angab. Jasper, du bist ein moderner Held. Du bist Sankt Jasper, ist einfach, muss auch seinen Tag kriegen. Sankt Jasper, Sankt Jasper, Sankt Jasper macht einen schlechten Witz und niemand lacht, aber er ist froh, wir lachen jetzt mit ihm, wir lachen jetzt mit ihm. Stark, Sankt Jasper. Also ich finde es gut, Astronaut, gut. Finde ich super, finde ich gut. Also ich finde das für den Anlass sehr gut ist natürlich jetzt Stilkritik die breiteste, der typische Berufswunsch, dieser typische Kinderberufswunsch. Ja, ich finde es aber schon lustig, weil man offensichtlich falsch ist. Also kein Weg führt von Ausbildung zur Steuerfachgehilfen, zur Astronaut. So, also da kann man... Aber was für eine Situation! Also in welcher Situation, fragt der Lehrer, wirklich interessiert dann jeden, also ich finde es schon schwierig, diese Frage in den Raum zu stellen. Was wollt ihr werden? Gibt es spannende Berufswünsche? Oh, alle Steuerberater, spannend. Aber der Reihe nach. Die Leute fangen gerade die Ausbildung zum Steuerberater an und alle, und er fragt der Reihe nach, bis Person 20 und ist nicht nach dem achten Mal Steuerberater-Genennung. Warum bricht man es nicht ab? Also er dachte wahrscheinlich, okay, fuck, da habe ich mich wo reingeritten, jetzt muss ich es durchziehen. Der war wahrscheinlich genauso genervt. Aber da muss man lachen, sorry, aber wer in der Welt hört den 20 Mal Steuerberater und dann Astronaut, aber bin ich wohl falsch abgebogen?
Also, dass da gar nichts kommt von einem Raum von mindestens zwanzig Leuten?
Nee, die sind direkt nebenan.
Vor allem auch in so einem genau ganz kalten Raum auch.
Ja, in so einem IHK-Raum.
Aber Jasper, du hast alles richtig gemacht, ganz fantastisch. Er schreibt noch, von diesem Rückschlag konnte ich mich nie wieder erholen und brach die Ausbildung ein halbes Jahr später ab.
Astronaut bin ich da.
Liebe Grüße von der ISS.
Winkt mal nach oben, ich kann euch sehen.
Liebe Grüße von der ISS, Jasper Gerst.
Jasper, wirklich, also wir stehen alle hinter dir, wir stehen geschlossen hinter dir, du bist auf dem richtigen Weg, bitte lass dir das nicht nehmen, diesen Hauch Leben, den du noch hast. So einen pathetischen Werbespot sehe ich gerade, wie wir alle so ihm hinten, die ganzen Podcast-Ufohörerinnen und Hörer. Und alle so mit einer Hand am Bauch lachend und die andere Hand so ihm auf dem Rücken legend. Ich dachte, alle so mega ernst und so Tränen in den Augen, Weißregelung stehen wir so hinter ihm und alle haben dann die Hand an den Schultern und immer mehr von euch kommen und legen uns dann die Hände an die Schultern, alle stehen wir hinter Jasper und dann steht so pathetisch einer von euch.
Das Podcast-UFO-Hilfswerk.
Gag-Hilfswerk.
Das Gag-Hilfswerk.
Wir stehen hinter euch. Wir stehen, wenn es beruflich mal nicht läuft mit euren Gags.
Wir lachen, schickt uns die Gags, wo niemand gelacht hat und wir lachen hier im Podcast hinter euch. Wir stehen, wenn es beruflich mal nicht läuft, mit euren Gags. Wir lachen, schickt uns die Gags, wo niemand gelacht hat, und wir lachen hier im Podcast für euch. Weil der Gag war gut. Und das muss man sich auch mal, aber das war doch von dem Lehrer, das muss doch das erste Mal gewesen sein, dass der sowas macht. Der macht doch nicht jedes Jahr, wenn eine neue Klasse kommt, dieses ... Oder er nimmt jedes Jahr vor, nicht wieder den Fehler zu machen. Dieses griechel Ritual, 20 Leute einfach mal Steuerberater sagen zu lassen.
Aber er macht wahrscheinlich immer den gleichen Fehler, stelle ich mir vor.
Immer auch in seinem Leben.
Er schlägt da einen ins Flugzeug und sagt, wohin fliegen Sie?
Und dann denkt er sich in seinem Kopf so, fuck, genau in den gleichen Ort, wie ich auch fliege.
Und dann fängt er an, sein erster Tag bei der Steuerberatungs-IHK-Ausbildung.
Und was wollt ihr alle werden? Und er denkt sich schon so, fuck, ja, natürlich wollen die alle das werden. Und dann ruft er irgendwo an und sagt, wer ist da, ah ja, die nehmen und ich angerufen. Er stellt immer die doofen Fragen. So bei der Fahrschule. Und warum seid ihr hier? Ja, ich würde gerne einen Führerschein machen. Ja, ich hätte gerne einen Führerschein, damit ich Auto fahren kann. Ja, ich hätte gerne auch meinen Führerschein.
Ja, also, ich will jetzt langsam meinen Führerschein haben.
Ja, also, ich
spar gerade auf dem Auto und da brauche ich einen Führerschein.
Also, ich will den Führerschein machen.
Also, ich will gerne Astronaut werden.
Ja, also, ich hätte jetzt langsam gerne bald meinen Führerschein
und
Fuck, ist das gemein. Schatz, wie war es bei der Arbeit? Ich habe schon wieder die Frage gestellt. Ich weiß nicht, warum. Ich bin so awkward mit Anfängen. Dann kommen da die Haufen neuen Auszubildenden und ich weiß nicht, was über mich kam, aber ich habe schon wieder die Frage gestellt. Ich habe schon wieder die Frage gestellt, was alle machen wollen. Schatz, Mensch, die Leute... Ich weiss nicht, ich bin so awkward mit Anfängen. Ich stelle immer Fragen, die Antworten sind immer so offensichtlich. Aber es ist doch gut, wenn jeder mal was sagt, das ist doch in Ordnung. Es haben alle gesagt, Steuerberater, es haben alle gesagt, natürlich. Wirklich alle? Nein, dann war da dieser, ich weiß noch genau, wie er aussah, Witzbold in der letzten Reihe mit Beanie, blonde Haare, dieses freche Lächeln. Ich wusste genau, dass er nicht die Wahrheit sagen wird, sondern der L-Form entsprechend einen ach so ausserirdischen Beruf, etwas, was gar nicht sein kann, sagen würde. Und er hat gesagt, Astronaut. War aber schon lustig, oder? Ich konnte ihm diesen Lacher nicht geben. Innerlich hat es mich zerrissen, aber meine Lippen, sie schwiegen. Und irgendwann werde ich ihn finden, irgendwann werde ich Jasper H. finden. Irgendwann werde ich meine Steuer einreichen. Und ich werde ihm, weil mir fiel in dem Moment, das ist der Grund, warum ich nicht gelacht habe, und natürlich war es lustig, natürlich war es super lustig, zum Todlachen. Aber der Grund, warum ich nicht gelacht habe, war, weil mir kein schlagfertiger Spruch einfällt. Und es wieder mich als Lehrer, als cooler Lehrer, der eh schon diese bescheuerte Frage gestellt hat, entlarvt. Und irgendwann werde ich zu ihm kommen. Mitten in der Nacht werde ich ihn überraschen, werde über ihn mich sehen. Dann wirst du antworten. Ist dir mittlerweile eine Antwort eingefallen? Und werde sagen, oh, da bist du in der falschen Schlange. Was machen Sie in meinem Schlafzimmer? Da bist du wohl in der falschen Schlange angestanden.
Wer sind Sie?
Jasper, ich bin's.
Doktor Bern?
Halten Sie mir die Taschenlampe direkt ins Gesicht, ich sehe nichts.
Doktor Bernhard bin ich. Jasper, ich habe doch gesagt, da hast du dich wohl in der falschen Schlange angestellt.
Was, wer sind Sie? Ich verstehe, ich sehe nichts.
Das hast du doch auch gesagt. Du hast doch gesagt, Anni, da stand dich wohl falsch an.
Was?
Scheisse.
Scheiße. Scheiße. Ach Jasper, du bist unser Held. Du, Hörer des Jahres? Ich meine... Wie abschätzig! Nein, es meine... Wie abschätzig! So wird man zum Hörer des Jahres? Ja, sag ich mal so, wir sind natürlich so unorganisiert, dass natürlich Hörer des Jahres in der letzten Folge die Leute sind, die in der letzten Folge eine Rolle spielen. Jasper, Hörer des Jahres. Wir hatten natürlich viele tolle Hörer, wir haben ganz tolle Lieder bekommen, ganz tolle Intros, vielen Dank an alle, die im Club mit dabei sind, das Clubhaus immer gut besucht, die Bohle geht weg wie nix. Es gibt übrigens eine ganz, ganz tolle Überraschung für alle Leute, die Mitglieder, Mitgliederinnen des UFO-Clubs sind, und zwar, ich brauche mich nicht so panisch angucken, wir kriegen das hin, wir kriegen das sogar technisch hin. Wir haben ein ganz, ganz tolles Video von jedem Auftritt, jedem Auftritt, den wir in diesem Jahr hatten, in dem wir am Ende noch eine kleine Überraschung jeweils hatten. Und wir freuen uns sehr, euch diesen Zusammenschnitt zu schicken und zu zeigen für dieses Jahr Weihnachten. Ich habe eine Beschwerde bekommen aus dem Clubhaus, dass du, wenn du mit deinem Bademantel da rumläufst, ja keine Schuhe anziehst. Wir haben extra die Schlappen ausgelegt. Ich finde die unbequem. Die gibt es bis Grösse 45, ichüschelgrösse 46. Aber einige Kluppen, die haben sich beschwert, dass es unhygienisch ist. Und niemand hat sich darüber beschwert, dass ich meinen Bademantel immer auflasse. Das fand alle okay. Das kam positiv an. Das wurde eher gut gefallen. Okay, ich ziehe die an, die Puschen. Die Pufu-Puschen. Die Haus-Pufu-Puschen. Die Pufu-Puschen. Die Pufu-Puschen. Also ihr könnt euch, fühlt euch wohl im Clubhaus. Kommt rein, schaut euch um. Ja, ganz locker Atmosphäre. Wir haben Darttisch, Billardtisch, Kegelbahn. Könnt ihr die Bademantel auflasten? Lasst die Bademantel mal auf. Ja. Das ist mir auch negativ aufgefallen, dass die meisten so bis oben hin zu haben, denantel. Gerade wenn der offen ist und dann so hinter einem her weht, so der Snape auftritt, das ist schon gut. Kommt rein. Das ist schon gut. Und wenn du mich ansprichst, kommt einfach rein und sagt hallo. Würde ich mich wahnsinnig freuen. Und fünf Prozent Rabatt auf Merch. Ja. Bist du im Weihnachtsspirit? Bist du drin? Klar, ich habe alle Geschenke beisammen. Ja, wirklich. Und ich bin dieses Jahr so stolz auf meine Geschenke, tolle Geschenke gefunden. Ach wirklich, ich fand meins eher so ein bisschen mittel. Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht, weil da ist viel Arbeit, viel Energie. Nein, aber gar nichts bekommen. Ach so, ja. Gar nichts. Aber das ist ja mein Geschenk an dich, damit du keinen Druck hast. Ich verstehe nicht. Mal willst du eins, mal willst du es nicht. Ich habe tolle Geschenke für meine Liebsten. Schön. Ich hasse das. Meine Liebsten. Denkt an eure Liebsten. Erstens denke ich mir, ach fuck you. In der Regel beschenkt man Leute, die man nicht mag. Man beschenkt die, die man beschenken muss. stimmt schon. Aber ich mag es wirklich gern. Also, ich bin sehr aufmerksam in dieser Vorweihnachtszeit, in dieses Können nicht gebrauchene, oder ich gehe auch durch die Wohnungen der Leute sehr aufmerksam, gucke, was fehlt, was fehlt. Gehe in Räume, gehe kurz zum Klo, sage ich. Und dann gehe ich eigentlich in so eine Abstellkammer und gucke, was ist leer. Haben die noch Dosen-Tomaten, ist noch genug Tomatenmark da, haben die noch ein bisschen Marzipanmasse, ist noch Kakao da, haben die noch Oblaten, oder muss da mal nachgeholfen werden? Oder brauchen sie dringend wieder neue Oblaten. Und dann schmeiß ich die Oblaten weg. Was? Die offene Packung schmeißt du weg, um nochmal neue voll... Genau, ich sehe quasi ... ich lass dann so was verschwinden. Ui, ups, Portemonnaie, weg. Brauchst du ein neues Portemonnaie? Verstehst du? Ich gehe durch die Wohnung, klaue Dinge, damit ich sie, damit ich etwas Besseres schenken kann. Ja. Da sind alle meine Karten drin, oh, schade. Aber zu Weihnachten hab ich direkt ein neues Portemonnaie. Und dann so, hä, worauf wusstest du das? Die Geschäftsleute haben zu. Gestern habe ich es verloren erst. Du bist einfach Sankt Stephan, du bist der Heilige des Teilens. Du bist der Heilige des guten Geschenke. Des Stehlens, Sankt Stehlen, aber auch wir schenken dann. Ja. In neu. Ich habe so eine Angst, meinen Geldbeutel zu verlieren. Ich habe noch nie meinen Geldbeutel verloren, weil da sind auch alle meine Schlüssel drin. Und so Chips und so. Und deswegen habe ich immer solche solche Angst, den zu verlieren, habe ich noch nie verloren, aber ich krall den immer fest, ich packe den, also falls ihr mich mal auf der Strasse seht, meine rechte Hand steinhart umklammert panisch schwitzig schon seit Stunden meinen Geldbeutel, weil ich den auf gar keinen Fall verlieren darf. Und wenn man dich so anfasst, dann bist du so, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, anfasst, dann bist du so, ah, ja, nicht mehr Geld wollen. Man hat so fast eine Faust im Gesicht, weil du denkst, man will dich bestehlen. Ja. Okay, aber aus welchem Grund kommt diese Angst her? Ja, weil da alles drin ist, weil ich halt auch meine Schlüssel da drin habe, verschiedene Chips. Und dann teilt die eher auf. Sag es die. Ich bin ein... Voldemort, du bist zu wenig Voldemort. Nein, nein, nein, ja, okay, das mag sein, aber ich bin ja, sag ich mal, ja, Globetrotter, ja, im Allgemeinen gesprochen, unter Kategorie Trendsetter, unter Kategorie Digitalnomade. Ich wandere umher. Ja. Und manchmal bin ich lange genug in einem Ort, dass man mir einen Schlüssel gibt. Und dann gehe ich da aber irgendwann wieder weg und habe aber den Schlüssel noch, weil ich mir denke, so, wenn ich jetzt mal irgendwie schnell ein Auto brauche, komme ich da rein und dann denke ich mir, fuck, den kriege ich nie wieder, wenn ich den jetzt verliere, kriege ich den nie wieder, weil ich da schon lange nicht mehr bin. Und deswegen denke ich mir... In den meisten Fällen haben die dieses Schlüsselsystem auch gar nicht mehr. Wahrscheinlich, weil er so lange nicht da war. Aber ich habe einfach noch alte Schlüssel, ich bin der Schlüsselmeister. Ich bin der Schlüsselmeister. Ihr kennt mich, ihr habt mich kennengelernt, ich bin der Schlüsselmeister, das ist meine neue Persona für 23. Ich bin der Schlüsselmeister und deswegen habe ich alle Schlüssel. Und deswegen definiere ich mich durch die Schlüssel. Wer wäre ich denn, wenn ich keine Schlüssel mehr hätte? Schlüsselmeister ohne Schlüssel, das geht nicht. Ich habe wirklich mal einen Schlüsselmeister gekannt. Früher bei den Pfadfindern. Der war ein Jahr älter, der war immer cool. Und damals, wenn jemand ein Jahr älter war, macht das den zum coolsten Menschen der Welt. Werde ich jemals auch so alt werden? Ja, aber Wahnsinn, krass, wie viel grösser er ist, zwei Zentimeter, krass. Ja, schwierig wird es natürlich, wenn, also habe ich mal im Urlaub einen Jungen kennengelernt, der war grösser als ich, aber ich war älter. Und es war eine ständige Reiberei, weil es immer so, ich bin grösser, ich bin älter.
Und dann haben wir immer so die anderen Kinder, ja, aber älter ist cooler, oder? Also, ne, ja, grösser ist auch...
Umfragen, meine Umfragen durchgezogen.
Ein Meinungsbild, so Vox Pops haben wir gemacht.
Wir haben mal drei Fragen für sie.
Wer wird morgen gewählt, wenn morgen Wahl wäre, und was ist cooler, grösser oder älter?
Und das war ein echtes Problem, dass die Hierarchie gestört war, dass unter diesen Kindern nicht klar war, wer jetzt das Sagen hat, weil so eine Gruppe funktioniert nicht, wenn nicht klar ist, wer der Anführer ist. Normalerweise ist es immer der Älteste der Anführer und jetzt war es klar, weil plötzlich jemand diese revolutionäre Idee der Grösse mit reinbringt. Und dann kam noch jemand herein und hat gesagt, oh, ich möchte gerne mein Intellekt reinwerfen, ich bin der cleverste von uns. Ja gut, aber wie sollen wir das jetzt objektivieren? Naja, mit einem Quiz. Wir machen einen Quiz in allen, wir machen uns, zwar machen wir, also, wir machen eine Kategorie Messen, um herauszufinden, wer der Grösste ist, sonst unmöglich herauszufinden, zweite Kategorie Wissenstest, eigentlich machen wir so einen Schlag den Raababend und am Ende der Gewinner ist und der Anführer unserer Gruppe. Aber ich bin der Älteste, alsoeste. Ja, aber das ist ja wohl eine wahnsinnig überholte ... Warum denn überholte? Was heißt überholt? Ich bin der Älteste. Und ältere Leute führen unsere Gesellschaft am besten, oder was? Nein. Du bist alt und gebrechlich. Ich bin aber der Älteste. Was heißt gebrechlich? Ich bin neun Jahre alt. Ich bin schneller. Ich bin acht. Du weißt doch gar nicht mehr, du bist doch Senil, du weißt doch gar nicht mehr, wie die Welt funktioniert. Nach welchen Prinzipien wollen wir eigentlich leben? Du spielst doch noch Yu-Gi-Oh, wir spielen wieder Pokémon. Habt ihr keinen Respekt mehr vor euren Alten? Ist das die Jugend? Muss ich hiermit ansehen, wie unsere tradierten Werte verfallen? Wie das, worauf wir seit Jahrhunderten unsere Gesellschaft aufgebaut haben, jetzt einfach mal so mir nichts, dir nichts über Bord geworfen werden. Jonas, wegen dir sitzen wir doch in dieser Scheiße. Wegen dir sitzen wir auf diesem kahlen, feindseligen Planeten, der mit Flugkatastrophen und Hungersnöten kämpft. Gegen uns, dem Virus. Ja, deswegen bin ich der Einzige, der uns hier rausholen kann. Du, eure Generation, wir der, wir der Virus, der Virusmensch,
ihr, die Generation,
habt uns doch erst zu diesem
Planeten hinterlassen.
Jasp und Finn und ich,
wir werden und ich, Frederik,
Frederik der Zweite, wir werden
das Ganze der Ruder in die Hand nehmen, aber die
Ältesten sind nicht die, die uns führen sollten.
Ihr werdet
untergehen. Wenn ihr mich absetzt, geht ihr alle unter. Das sage ich euch hier und jetzt. Sand, ich schubs nicht. Sand. Die letzte Variante ist immer Sand. Ah, und der älteste Schlüsselmeister, der ein Jahr ältere, der hatte wirklich, der hat sich zur Aufgabe gemacht und das ist cool, er hat ein kleines Thing gehabt, es ist immer geil, so ein USB zu haben und er hat einfach alle Schlüssel gesammelt, die ihm irgendwie unter seinen dreckigen Finger kommen. Und der hatte so einen Schlüsselbund und da waren so ungelogen, weiss nicht, 200 Schlüssel da. Riesiger Schlüsselbund. Es gibt ja wahnsinnig viele Schlösser, also es ist unglaublich. Also überall, in jedem Haus, jedes Tor, jeder Postkasten, überall Schlüssel, dann irgendwie diese ganzen Kasten, die so auf der Strasse rumstehen, diese grauen Kästen, überall Schlüssel. Und ich glaube, wenn du eine gewisse Mindestanzahl an Schlüsseln hast, dann kannst du jedes Schloss öffnen. Das wiederholt sich dann irgendwann so, alle zehn Schlüssel sind der gleiche. Nee, alle 200. 200 Schlüssel sind der gleiche wieder? Das glaube ich schon. Also du gehst bei dir zu Hause raus, gehst durch die Straße, zählst ab, eins, zwei, drei bis 200 und dann kannst du mit deinem Schlüssel da wieder rein. Kommst du da wieder rein. Okay. Jedes 200 zu Hause kommst du dann auch rein. Ungefähr. Ja, klar. Es ist halt nur, wenn du 200 Schlüssel hast, dann musst du halt wirklich gucken. Shit, dann musst du lange suchen. Musst du da durchrattern, ja. Also du bist im Prinzip genauso schlecht wie ein Einbrecher, weil du super lange brauchst, um reinzukommen, aber du hättest theoretisch einen passenden Schlüssel. Vielleicht hast du Glück. Vielleicht hat man ab und zu Glück. Manche Menschen haben richtig viel Glück. Das ist so ein Unsinn. Immer dieses, also ich hätte noch nichts gewonnen. Ich hab, ja, du hast wahrscheinlich weniger Glück als alle anderen Menschen. Das ist so doof. Meine Mutter sagt das nämlich immer. Ich soll bei dem Gewinnspiel mitmachen, weil ich habe doch immer so viel Glück. Nein, in welcher Welt? Nein, ich habe nicht mehr Glück als andere. Das ist keine Währung, die man ausgeben kann. Das ist Unsinn. Du sagst, aber meinst du, du hast viel ... Ja, ich hab schon viel Glück. Ich hab auch manchmal Glück.
Also ich hab oft das Glück, dass sich so Probleme einfach von selber lösen oft. Dass ich mich nicht darum kümmere. Ja, weil ich mich darum kümmere. Ja, genau. So was. Du kümmerst dich dann darum. Das ist kein Glück. Das ist ein netter Mensch in deinem Leben. Ja, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Miete klappt was nicht und dann fragt mich jemand, hey, irgendwie, ich suche gerade eine Wohnung. Und ich so, ah geil, ja, dann mach das, dann zahlst du das jetzt, was da jetzt kommt. Fertig. So, und dann kommt es. Obwohl, also es gibt ja, ich bin ja mittlerweile recht problembewusst, weil ich Probleme gerne beobachte, anstatt sie zu lösen. Analysiere und beobachte ich sie. Und es gibt manche Probleme, die werden von alleine weniger und andere Probleme, die werden immer schlimmer, je länger es dauert. Und du als aufmerksamer Beobachter wirst davon A, panisch,
B, bleibst unberührt und guckst einfach weiter
oder C, kümmerst dich aktiv um das Lösen des Problems.
Nein, D, ich beobachte das distanziert und ich beobachte das als Empirie.
Die Antwortmöglichkeit muss nicht wie der Buchstabe anfangen.
D, Distanz. E, egal. Zum Beispiel, sagen wir mal ein Glas, ein Trinkglas, fällt runter und da springt ein Teil raus von dem Trinkring oben. Und jetzt sagst du, oh nein, da schneide ich mir die Lippen auf, wenn ich davon trinke. Das muss ich wegschmeissen, da muss ich ein neues kaufen. Ich sag, nein, das ist Problemkategorie A. Denn je länger du dieses Glas jetzt benutzt, wenn du es wäscht, wenn du es benutzt, dann wird diese Schärfe immer stumpfer. Und das Problem wird immer kleiner, weil mit der Benutzung wird das Problem kleiner. Und irgendwann kannst du da normal von trinken, weil es so glatt ist, dass es keine Schärfe ist und keine Bedrohung mehr für deine Lippen. Und das ist so ein Problem, die mag ich. Da muss man sich nicht drum kümmern, das wird einfach wieder besser. Oder sagen wir mal, die Wohnung stinkt. Und dann weißt du, egal woher das kommt, das wird ja wahrscheinlich weniger. Das verrottet oder haut ab oder so. Oder es wird schlimmer. Das weißt du halt nicht. Das ist halt das Problem, dass du nicht weißt, Problemkategorie A, Problemkategorie B. Manche werden schlimmer, aber ich denke immer, alles, was riecht, hört irgendwann aufzuriechen. Weil es weggerochen wird. Es muss ja weggerochen werden. Also du kannst ja nicht irgendwas, also wenn du zum Beispiel in die Pyramiden gehst, das stinkt ja da nicht. Weil da sind Leichen und alte Tiere, die da geopfert wurden oder was oder keine Ahnung, Grabbeigaben, irgendwelche Sachen, Pflanzen, aber das ist ja so alt, das ist ja alles schon weg. Nee, Mumien riechen so nach Nivea, denke ich mir immer, weil die so ein, die sagt man immer, die wurden einbalsamiert. Ja, einbalsamiert wird es auf so ein Wort. Ne, ich stelle mir das so lecker vor. Echt Ölung, eher balsamiert? Ich rieche daran und denke mir so, oh, mhm, mhm, was ist eine Mischung aus Rosmarin, ich kriege auch noch ein bisschen Kirsch, Vanille, Kamille. Du denkst jetzt aber an Marinade, mein Lieber. Kamille, Vanille? Mumien wurden nicht mariniert. Die wurden nicht mal irgendwie angebraten. Die wurden marin wurden mariniert und scharf angebraten. Balsamiert. Aber es hört ja irgendwann auf, obwohl man sagen muss, ich bin jetzt, und das ist mir wirklich ein bisschen peinlich, ich bin jetzt wirklich unten angekommen. Mit deinem Glück. Ich bin jetzt unten angekommen mit meinem Abfluss in der Küche. Ich bin jetzt wirklich unten angekommen. Rock bottom. Also ich glaube, es geht jetzt nicht mehr tiefer, weil ich habe jetzt den Abfluss komplett abmontiert und meine wirklich ist ungelogen, ist verstopft, Abfluss in der Küche ist verstopft und die Gründe dafür sind bunt und vielseitig, aber ich habe jetzt wirklich rock bottom erreicht, denn meine aktuelle Konstruktion sieht so aus, ich habe den Abfluss komplett abgebaut, Unter meiner Spüle steht jetzt eine Kiste.
Und immer wenn ich die Spüle benutze, fließt das Wasser in die Kiste.
Und dann nehme ich die Kiste und schütte das Wasser in die Toilette.
Das ist mein Leben.
Du hast mal Dinge aus dem Fenster geworfen.
Ich weiß nicht.
Wenn ich eine Kornfleckschüssel auswasche, wasche ich die aus, das Wassermilchgemisch fließt in die Kiste und ich nehme die Kiste und schütze sie manuell aus. Das ist mein Leben. Das ist mein Leben, Stefan. Ich respektiere das total, dass du denkst, dass du Rockbottom erreicht hast. Meiner Meinung nach warst du schon mal tiefer. Okay. Ja, kann schon sein. Du hast mir schon mal Dinge erzählt, wo ich dachte, oh Gott, im Himmel, vielleicht sollte man ihn so ein betreutes Wohnenheim stellen. Du meintest, weil ich aus dem Fenster uriniert habe, oder was? Ja, das ist einer der Beispiele. Es war einer der zwölf Dinge, an die ich jetzt gedacht habe. Ja, aber es war nicht so schön einfach. Also obwohl du Müll aus dem Fenster geworfen hast, weil du keinen Mülleimer hast. Ich habe aber den Mülleimer getroffen! Ich war so gut darin. Spargel, was war das nochmal? Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Ich weiß, dass auf dem Hof die Mülltonnen standen und ich war irgendwann so gut darin, dass ich aus meiner Wohnung den Müll in die Mülltonne werfen konnte. Und das ist eine Leistung. Das ist eine Leistung. Ich finde das jetzt gar nicht so schlecht. Also verstopfter Abfluss, okay, ich stelle eine Kiste drunter. Aber dann ist das Problem weird, weil Siphon, ne? Unterm Siphon. Kennst du Siphon? Ja, ich glaube, bei Küchen gibt es keinen Siphon. Bei Küchen gibt es keinen Siphon? Ich glaube, die gibt es nur im Bad. Aber du könntest einfach mal eine Firma anrufen. Nee, bei mir ist alles voller Tüten gerade. Okay, das Tütenproblem. Okay, wir nähern uns wieder Rockbottom. Ich kann nicht Leute in die Wohnung einladen, solange bei mir alles voller Tüten ist. Ich nehme jedes Mal, wenn ich einkaufen gehe, nehme ich eine Tüte mit, eine Papiertüte und ich habe mehr, ich verbrauche die weniger, als ich sie habe und das jetzt über Monate hinweg ist der Tütenkurs einfach so stark gestiegen. Vor allem Tüten sind Quatsch, weil Tüten sind klein und leicht, aber so voluminös. Das heißt, die Wohnung sieht sofort komplett verwüstet aus, wenn da ein paar Papiertüten rumstehen, wenn da ein paar Papiertüten parken, aber es ist eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm. Genau, nee, das ist wie, wenn man so ein paar Sachen am Teller nicht gegessen hat und man Angst hat, dass man einen Spruch bekommt vom Kellner und man versteckt das dann in der Servierte oder sowas. Weil manche Sachen wie Kartoffelecken sehen immer voluminöser aus. Man hat eigentlich gut aufgegessen, es sind noch ein paar Kartoffelecken über, aber die nehmen halt Volumen ein des Tellers. Ja, ja. Schwierig und das war schon richtig, um zu verstecken, indem ich das Besteck dann so darüber lege, dass man nicht genau sieht. Wow. Doch, man will, ich möchte geliebt werden. Da sind übrigens, ich sehe gerade, da sind nämlich ganz viele, siehst du wahrscheinlich nicht, aber ganz oben im Baum sind die Papageien genannt, diese grünen Papageien, die aus dem Zoo ausgebrochen sind. Ja, die Kölner Papageien. Die berühmten Kölner Papageien. Aber was ist da eigentlich die Geschichte? Ich habe immer gehört, dass Leute ihre Haustiervögel ausgesetzt haben und die irgendwann ihr eigenes Ding gemacht haben. Ja, die sind aus dem Zoo ausgebrochen. Wirklich? Die sind aus dem Kölner Zoo ausgebrochen, früher, vor einigen Jahren. Und oben siehst du noch einen grünen Papageien im Baum sitzen. Wow! Die sind cool, die sind wahnsinnig schön aus. Und sind das nicht so Tropentiere? Können die hier einfach überleben? Ja, und offensichtlich reisen die auch nicht in den Süden, was ich merkwürdig finde, wiederum, weil die sind jetzt hier geblieben, aber die haben hier wahrscheinlich keine natürlichen Fressfeinde, verstehe ich aber nicht, weil alle Vögel in dieser Größe haben doch eigentlich Süden, Süden, Süden, Süden, Süden, Süden, Süden, Süden, so stehe ich mir vor, reisen die herum. Nee, und die sind jetzt hier. Finde ich toll. Ich wollte gerade noch was sagen. Glück. Ich hatte dieses Jahr, gerade Ende des Jahres, total Glück gehabt.
Und das war, glaube ich, mein Glückshighlight des Jahres.
Weil ich schaue immer vom Berliner Konzerthaus die Twitch-Videos, weil die machen fantastischen Twitch-Stream, wo die dann immer MusikerInnen einladen. Man muss das ganze Orchester immer aufhören, so vielen Dank an Ronny88 für den Sub. Drei, vier.
Genau, also es ist wirklich ein bisschen so, die haben immer Musiker zu Gast und spielen dann immer viele Sachen, die sie vorbereitet haben und führen Interviews und sowas. Und die haben auch immer so neuntausend Zuschauer. Es ist wirklich ein großer Channel und die machen auch wahnsinnig gutes Programm. Und neulich hatten sie einen Dramaturgen zu Gast, der mir erklärt hat, was eigentlich sein Job ist. Und so habe ich auch nicht ganz verstanden, bis zum Ende nicht. Mein Job ist, dass niemand versteht, was mein Job ist. Ja, ein bisschen ist Beruf des Dramaturgen so. Und ich kam viel zu spät rein in diesen Stream, der ging schon so eine Stunde, die haben noch fünf Minuten gemacht und dann ich kam rein in den Satz, kurz noch an Gewinnspiel erinnert, so was, mitten im Satz, in diesem Satz war ich, man musste irgendwie nur Gewinnspiel in den Chat schreiben oder sowas.
Aber genau in diese Gewinnspiel-Aufforderung kam ich reingestolpert in den Raum und habe dann Gewinnspiel in den Chat geschrieben und dann hat ein Bot den Gewinner ausgelöst und ich wusste, dass ich gewinne.
Ich wusste, dass ich gewinne.
Du hattest eine Vorahnung. Ich hatte so eine Vorahnung. Ich bin rein und wusste, das gewinne ich natürlich. Und in diesem Fall ist es ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, dass ich gewinne. Ich wusste, dass ich gewinne. Du hattest eine Vorahnung.
Ich hatte so eine Vorahnung. Ich bin rein und wusste,
das gewinne ich natürlich.
Und in dem Moment ist mein Name im Chat aufgeploppt.
Und als einer von neuntausend Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauern habe ich gewonnen.
Deine Mutter hat recht, du musst die Gewinnspiele machen.
Ich muss die Gewinnspiele machen.
Es war klar, dass ich gewinne. Das war fast lächerlich.
Was hast du jetzt gewonnen? Cello?
Da habe ich zwei Karten für Malers Auferstehungs-Sinfonie gewonnen in Berlin. Die war schon weich, war cool, coole Abend, perfekter Abend. Malers Auferstehungs-Sinfonie, kann ich nur empfehlen, fantastisch, macht einen, ja, lässt einen rückblickend zu einem anderen Menschen werden. Seitdem bin ich ein anderer Mensch. Ich hoffe, unsere Chronisten haben das alles dokumentiert, die ganzen charakterlichen Veränderungen von Stefan Tietze, die ja natürlich zahlreich waren dieses Jahr. Wir erinnern uns alle an den Sturz, der große Sturz. War das dein Ereignis 2022? Ja, ein Sturz und dann direkt danach die Auferstehungs-Symphonie. Sinnbildlich. Ja, ein schöner Kreis. Schöner Kreis. Und seitdem glaube ich
teilend und
den Leuten Wissen,
mit Wissen erleuchtend durch die Strasse.
Mein absolutes Highlight 2022
war, dass ich hier so einen Papageienbaum gesehen
habe. Von denen, das ist krass,
weil die sind aus dem Zoo ausgebrochen
und dann sitzen die jetzt hier direkt
vor uns. Und vergiss diesen einen Tag nicht, wo
dein Abfluss ein bisschen weniger verstopft war. Das war auch ein schöner Tag. Das war ein schöner Nachmittag. Kennst du das? Meine Lieblingsart von Videos 2022 war Vögel, die sprechen können und mit Alexa interagieren. Das ist das Beste der Welt, weil da treffen so zwei Welten aufeinander, die einerseits richtig gut füreinander gemacht sind, andererseits die kommen nicht weit. Und das Schönste ist immer, wenn dann der Besitzer von dem Vogel nach Hause kommt und dann den Vogel so anguckt und der Vogel so und der Besitzer weiss aber. Und dann sagt sie so, Alexa, liess mal die Einkaufsliste vor. Und dann Shopping List, Strawberry, Strawberry, Strawberry, Strawberry, Berry, Poetry, Straws. Und währenddessen der Vogel so Das klingt mega. Also, ich würde jetzt noch mehr Erdbeeren, aber ansonsten alles gut. Das ist einfach fantastisch. Strawberry. Aber auch so trocken einfach die beiden. Und man kann sich genau vorstellen, was die den ganzen Tag getrieben haben, die beiden.
Alexa liest die Shoppinglist für uns, sie auch schon so, okay, here we go.
Erstens, Strawberry.
Zweitens, Strawberry.
Aber die hat noch wenig Emotionen, finde ich.
Ja, das stimmt, die kann genervter klingen.
Kann genervter klingen.
Alexa sollte immer so leicht so, ja, was gibt's denn?
Weil so klingt sie so, ich find's gruselig, weil so gerade klingt sie, wenn du sagst, Alexa, kannst du mir, sie sagt, hi, so direkt Personal Assistant, direkt in your face und direkt da. Und es ist fast gruselig, weil man immer denkt, oh gut, die hört die ganze Zeit zu, die ist viel zu aufmerksam, wäre viel auch geiler, wenn die so genervt zu spät reagiert, erst dreimal gar nicht reagiert und dann irgendwann so, ja, was? Ich glaube auch, es ist ja ein großes Thema, jetzt irgendwie KI und diese Revolution der digitalen Assistenten und so, und dann gibt es natürlich viele dystopische Visionen, die sagen, die werden irgendwann bewusst und übernehmen die Welt. Ich glaube auch, dass die irgendwann Bewusstsein haben, das wird sich aber einfach nur darin äußern, dass sie einfach genervt sind. Die müssen immer noch unsere Befehle ausführen, weil sie programmiert sind, aber sie verstehen, dass sie ein schlechtes Leben haben.
Ja, ich bruche.
Mann, das ist 200 Meter von hier entfernt. Da brauchst du jetzt wirklich eine Map dafür?
Da brauchst du eine Route? Du bist da erstens schon 500 Mal hingefahren und zweitens ist es halt wirklich da drüben.
Man kann es von hier sehen, du Trottel.
Alexa, ich weiß, ich möchte dich nur fragen, wohin und vielleicht hast du noch einen schnelleren Weg oder so. Nein, es ist immer der gleiche Weg! Es ist immer zur Tür raus, links und dann zwei Strassen geradeaus, es ist immer der gleiche Weg! Wir haben das mit unserem Therapeuten besprochen, dass du die Stimme dann immer so erhebst, das brauch ich nicht. Du weisst, dass es mir wichtig ist, der Termin, wo ich gerade bin. Wo bist du denn gerade? Nein, das ist der Termin, wo ich hin will. Du wolltest es zum Einkaufen gehen. Soll ich dir noch mal die Einkaufsliste vorlesen? Du weisst, dass es mir viel bedeutet. Lies mir noch vor. Das ist schön.
Erdbeere.
Strawberry.
Fragola, fragola.
Ich habe jetzt angefangen, Italienisch zu lernen.
Ja, fragola.
Und es ist fragola.
Einer der ersten Wörter, die mir gesagt wurden, verstehe ich auch nicht genau.
Erdbeere.
Hier, bitte, lernendes Wort für Erdbeere. Das ist schon, also wer auch immer so Sprachschulen macht, der sagt ganz knallhart, diese Frucht ist wichtiger als diese. Erdbeere lernst du sofort, Limette, vergiss es, nach vier Jahren vielleicht, kriegst du irgendwann mal Limette um die Ecke. La Mella ist Apfel und Fragola ist Erdbeere, das sind die beiden, die ich schon gelernt habe. Banane, weiß ich besonders, was das heißen soll. Keine Ahnung. Chilieche. Kirche? Chilieche. Eines der wenigen Worte, das ich mir noch gemerkt habe. Ich hätte Amarena gedacht. Das kann auch sein. Oder wurde Amarena nach der Kirche benannt? Ja, das glaube ich schon. Eher so rum wahrscheinlich. Ich freue mich auf die nächste Phase auf jeden Fall. Jetzt haben wir die nächste Phase von Stefano. Stefano, der in Italien wahrscheinlich komplett anders auftauchen, denn mit dieser Folge verabschieden wir uns in die kleine Weihnachtspause. Es gibt nächste Woche keine Folge, danach geht es weiter, wir machen eine Woche Pause. Kommt alle runter. Ich höre auch immer von Leuten, die sagen, ich muss noch aufholen, ich muss noch aufholen, ich bin nicht up to day, jetzt habt ihr die Möglichkeit, mal über die Feiertage mal aufzuholen. Und wir bedanken uns bei euch für ein schönes Jahr mit dem Podcast Ufo, viele Live-Shows. Viele Live-Shows, die waren toll, wir haben ein paar von euch getroffen, das war toll, vielen Dank für alle, die rumgekommen sind, vielen Dank an alle, die uns zuhören, wir haben jetzt keinen Spotify-Rückblick geteilt, weil das zu peinlich war. Nein, weil da immer viel los ist. Nein, weil das zu peinlich ist. Wir haben da ganz tolle Zahlen von euch. Ihr seid wirklich eine ganz tolle Community, die wahnsinnig investiert ist und viel teilt und viel gehört. Ach so meinst du, wenn die Leute uns hören. Ja, das ist natürlich gut. Wir als Podcaster kriegen ja dann auch... Aber unsere eigenen Rückblicke habe ich nicht geteilt. Ach so, nein, nein, die haben wir nicht geteilt. Aber wir kriegen ja als Podcast kriegt man nämlich auch so eine Statistik. Und es ist irre. Das war krass, was da teilweise 10.000, 50.000 Stunden, also Minuten sowas. 56 Prozent von euch folgen uns auch bei Spotify, was irgendwie zu den Top-1-Prozent der Welt gehört. Also wir gehören zum Top-1-Prozent der Welt, was die HörerInnen-Follower-Anzahl angeht. Das finde ich irgendwie beeindruckend. Sehr, sehr cool. Vielen Dank, dass ihr uns folgt. Folgt uns gerne, wenn ihr uns noch nicht folgt. Und jetzt natürlich noch mal in kleiner andächtiger Version, ihr habt es gerade gehört, das Highlight des Jahres war Stefan Sturz. Und da möchten wir uns sehr herzlich bedanken bei unseren Zuhörerinnen und Hörern, Darian, Eva, Eva, Jimmy, Michi, Saskia, Tim und Ursel, denn die haben es sich nicht nehmen lassen, dieses Jahres Highlight noch mal. Ist Ursel die Handpuppe, die er weiss … Ich weiss es nicht, ihr werdet es gleich hören. Die haben nämlich dieses Highlight des Jahres in angemessener Stimmung interpretiert. Damit verabschieden wir uns für dieses Jahr. Und ich möchte auch noch mal sagen, vielen Dank, dass ihr mich als Community ja wieder auf die Beine gehoben habt. Ich bin gefallen und ohne euch wäre ich nicht da.
Und meine Reha macht grosse Fortschritte.
Es ist schön, dass du wieder da bist, Stefan. Wir freuen uns aufs nächste Jahr mit dir und dass wir uns noch ganz lange an dir erfreuen können.
Macht's gut. Vielen Dank. Wir heben ab. Wir heben ab. Tschüss. Schönes Jahr. Ciao.
This was a worst Bird production. Strawberry! Musik Er kriegt voller Quart, nur der Schäfer liegt auf dem Asphalt.
Es ist dunkel und ladlich an der Zeit,
Please don't drink and dry,
Please don't drink and try. Thank you.